بعد غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا في فبراير 2022
حصلت حاله من الزعر الواسع بين الحكومات
الاوروبيه اللي حست بشكل مفاجئ وللمره
الاولى من وقت نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بتهديد عسكري بالحجم ده وكان على
راس الحكومات اللي حست بالتهديد ده هي
حكومات خط المواجهه اللي هي لها حدود مع
روسيا او قريبه منها بالشكل الكافي اللي
يخليها تحس بالخطر الروسي العسكري وعلى
راس البلاد دي كانت فنلندا وبولندا وطبعا
المانيا ولان المانيا بتعتبر القائد
الفعلي للاتحاد الاوروبي وهي اقوى اقتصاد
اوروبي ورابع اقوى اقتصاد في العالم بعد
امريكا والصين واليابان والحليف الاوروبي
الاهم للولايات المتحده اللي تزعمت تحالف
غربي سياسي واقتصادي وعسكري ضد الروس من
اللحظه الاولى قررت برلين انها ه تمشي ورا
واشنطن خطوه بخطوه وحاولت توحد اوروبا في
مواجهه جنرالات موسكو وبوتين من خلال شويه
مبادرات ومشاريع وبروتوكولات تعاون من
اهمها مبادره درع السماء الاوروبيه
المعروفه اختصارا باي اس اس اي المبادره
دي اطلقها المستشار الالماني اوليف شولتس
في 2022 بعد الغزو الروسي وقال ان الهدف
الرئيسي ليها هو تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه
الاوروبيه وشراء صواريخ وانظمه دفاع جوي
احدث واقوى من اللي بتملكه اوروبا حاليا
وبتشكر حاليا 19 دوله اوروبيه مع وجود دول
اساسيه لسه رافضه التوقيع هي فرنسا
وبولندا وايطاليا واسبانيا واللي عاوزين
يستخدموا انظمه عسكريه اوروبيه في
المبادره من انتاج شركات زي تالس واير باس
هنا هيظهر الكيان المحتل على الساحه ومن
وراء امريكا وهيعملوا مشكله للدول
المعترضه لانه عاوز يلهف حته كبيره من
تورته المل ارات اللي هتتوزع من خلال
مبادره درع السماء دي وبالفعل نجح الكيان
المحتل انه ياكل حته من التورته في اخر
سبتمبر اللي فات 2023 وقعت المانيا على
صفقه ضخمه قيمتها حوالي 3ه ونص مليار
دولار لشراء نظام صواريخ اسرائيلي اسمه
ارو 3 وده نظام تفوق سرعه صواريخه سرعه
الصوت ومصمم لاسقاط الصواريخ البالستيه
الروسيه والايرانيه وتم تطويره وانتاجه
بشكل مشترك بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
طبعا وزير دفاع الاحتلال يواف جلن تلوق
على الصفقه مع نظيره الالماني بورس
بيستوريوس انتهز الفرصه كعاده
الاسرائيليين في تلزيق اي حاجه فيها سيره
المانيا بالمحرك وقال ان التوقيع ده هو
حدث مؤثر لكل يهودي وكمل انه بعد 80 سنه
بس من نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه بقينا
في موقف اسرائيل بتتعا فيه مع المانيا
لبناء مستقبل امن اكثر الكلمتين دول اللي
مسؤولين حكومات الاحتلال بيقولوه دايما او
ما يشبههم في اي صفقه تقريبا مع المانيا
ما يقدروش يغطوا على السبب الحقيقي
والبسيط لفرحته بالصفقه دي وهي انها تعتبر
اكبر صفقه للصناعه العسكريه للاحتلال على
الاطلاق لكن الاهم انهم كلمتين بيوضح
استمرار السياسات الالمانيه اللي بتدعم
اسرائيل بشكل كامل لا يقبل النقاش في كل
المجالات تقريبا علشان كده بعد ما شنت
المقاومه هجومها معروف بطوفان الاقصى يوم
7 اكتوبر اللي فات على ما يعرف بمستوطنات
غلاف غزه لقينا الحكومه الالمانيه وجميع
الاحزاب السياسيه الرئيسيه هناك نطوا من
اماكنهم بمنتهى السرعه والتحفز وادانه في
كل حاره في المانيا تقريبا الهجوم
الحمساوي على اسرائيل وما كانش عندهم اي
استعداد من اي نوع لاي نقاش حوالين الصراع
او مظلوميه الفلسطينيين حاله التحفز
والجنان دي لا اكبر شريك تجاري لاسرائيل
في اوروبا ضد الفلسطينيين جه معاها ارتفاع
كبير في صادرات الاسلحه الالمانيه للكيان
المحتل وعلى المستوى السياسي والشعبي على
طول الحكومه الالمانيه حذرت عدد كبير من
المظاهرات المؤيده للفلسطينيين ومنعت
الاحتجاجات القليله المسموح بها من
استخدام شعارات سلميه بسيطه زي اوقفه
الحرب وبدات حامله لمقاطعه وفي قائمه من
الكتاب والفنانين والشخصيات الثقافيه
الالمانيه اللي عبوا عن التعاطف مع الشعب
الفلسطيني وحتى بعض الاحتجاجات الصغيره
اللي عملها بعض اليهود الالمان المعترضين
على السياسات الاسرائيليه ما سلمتش من
اللوم الالماني فاحنا النهارده عاوزين
نفهم الدعم الالماني غير المشروط ده
لاسرائيل ايه سببه يعني ليه الالمان
قالعين هدومهم للاسرائيليين بالشكل ده هل
ده بسبب مظلوميه الهولوكوست زي ما معظم
التحليلات في مختلف الاوقات بترجعها ولا
في اسباب ثانيه اقتصاديه وعسكريه اهم
بكتير من عقده الذنب دي دي ده جزء من اللي
هندردش فيه مع بعض في حلقه النهارده بس
بفكركم قبلها ان منصات ومواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي عامله قيود كبيره على انتشار
المحتوى المضاد للكيان المحتل فهمتكم
معانا باللايك والتفاعل مع الفيديو عشان
يظهر للناس انا اشرف ابراهيم المخبل
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي قبل ما نبدا انا وفريق المخبر
الاقتصادي هنكون حابين نشكر جدا شركه ت
فيت راعي حلقتنا النهارده شركه تلا فيت
اتاسس سنه 2017 وهي شركه فيتناميه اسسها
شاب مصري مكافح اسمه ضياء الدين امين
وبتصدر لاسواق مصر والسعوديه والاردن
وتركيا وغيرها منتجات مختلفه زي البن
والفلفل وجوز الهند والقرفه والكاجو
هتلاقوا تحت الفيديو بيانات شركه تلفيت
علشان لو انت مستورد وحابب تتعامل معاهم
وتستورد من خلالهم المنتجات دي دايما
العلاقات الالمانيه الاسرائيليه كان لها
طبيعه فريده شويه ويه خليتها حجر الزاويه
في السياسه الخارجيه الالمانيه وده مش
كلامي ده كلام انجلا ميركل قدام الكنيست
الاسرائيلي في 2008 زي ما شفنا في
الاقتباس اول الحلقه وكررتها على مر
السنين الطويله اللي قعدت فيها كمستشار
لالمانيا لحد سنتين فاتوا 2021 لو بصينا
هنلاقي ان المانيا هي الشريك الاقتصادي
الاهم لاسرائيل في الاتحاد الاوروبي ووصلت
قيمه التجاره الثنائيه بينهم لقرابته 9
مليار دولار السنه اللي فاتت 2022
وبالنسبه ل الاسرائيليين هنلاقي ان
الشركات الالمانيه عندهم هي الاهم بعد
الشركات الامريكيه في مشاريع البنيه
التحتيه الاسرائيليه لكن الاساس دايما
بيفضل على الاقل لحد اللحظه هو مساله
تعويضات الهولوكوست وغيرها اللي بتشكل حجر
الزاويه في العلاقات الالمانيه
الاسرائيليه ولو ركزنا هنلاقي ان المانيا
دفعت من سنه
1952 لحد 2021 اكت من 80 مليار يورو
كتعويضات لليهود منهم حوالي 29 مليار
دفعهم الالمان لضحايا الاضطهاد النازي
اللي عايشين في اسرائيل فعلشان نفهم
الالتزام الالماني الغريب وغير المفهوم ده
بالامن والرفاهيه الاقتصاديه الاسرائيليه
محتاجين ضروري نرجع لورا حبتين وتحديدا
لبدايه العلاقات الالمانيه الاسرائيليه من
سنه 1950 واللي نقدر نقول بلا مبالغه انها
كانت السبب الرئيسي والاهم في انقاذ
الكيان المحتل الوليد والهش من الانهيار
من وقت تاسيسها سنه 1949 هنلاقي ان
جمهوريه المانيا الاتحاديه اللي هي
المانيا الغربيه شاركت في الاحداث
والصراعات في الشرق الاوسط وتحديدا الصراع
العربي الاسرائيلي ولكن بشكل غير عادل
بالمره فهن الاقيها انها ساعدت الصهاينه
ودولتهم الوليده بمختلف اشكال المساعدات
الماديه والعسكريه من خلال التعويضات
والقروض والهدايا والخدمات الفنيه
والافراد المدربين والاسلحه المختلفه
وبالاخص من 1950 ل
1967 وتاثير المساعدات والمنح دي كان كبير
جدا لدرجه انه اثر على ميزان القوه بين
الاسرائيليين والعرب وادى افضليه واضحه
للكيان المحتل في الوقت ده اقتصاد دوله
الاحتلال كان بيواجه صعوبات كبيره قدام
استقرار الاقتصادات العربيه الرئيسيه
الراسخه يعني كان في نقص حاد في الكهربا
في اسرائيل لدرجه ان معظم المصانع والبيوت
على الاراضي المحتله تعرضت لفترات مطوله
من قطع الكه رب الجماعي في اوقات معينه كل
يوم وده خلى جميع قطاعات التنميه
الاقتصاديه في الكيان المحتل تتاثر ولو
بصينا على الاحتياطيات الاسرائيليه
الاجنبيه هنلاقيها تكاد تكون معدومه وفي
الوقت ده ما حدش كان راضي يديها قروض
ميسره هنا نقدر نعتبر ان المانيا الغربيه
شالت الكيان المحتل الوليد شيل من على
الارض وعملت له كل حاجه تقريبا علشان
تنقذه من الدمار اللي بيحصل ده ومن خلال
المبالغ الضخمه اللي ضخها الالمان
الغربيين في الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي على شكل
تعويضات قدر الصهاينه يشتروا النفط اللازم
لتشغيل المصانع لكن مساهمات الالمان ما
وقفتش زي ما قلنا على الفلوس بس وانما
مهندسي المانيا الغربيه بنوا وركبوا
للاسرائيليين خمس محطات توليد للطاقه
الكهربائيه وده ادى لتضاعف انتاج الكهرباء
للكيان المحتل اربع مرات في ثلاث سنين بس
من
1993 ل 1956 ومن مساعدات الضخمه اللي
عملتها المانيا الغربيه برده للكان المحتل
ان مهندسيها حسنوا ووسعوا الشبكه
الاسرائيليه للنقل والتوزيع وده كان عنصر
مهم جدا ساعد الاسرائيليين على بسط
سيطرتهم على الاراضي الفلسطينيه فحلا
الالمان مدوا خط سكه حديد جديد لبئر السبع
وجددوا نص خط القطار من القدس لتل ابيب
وسلموا الصهاينه 400 عربيه قطارات وعدد من
محركات التحويل ومعدات الاشارات والتنسيق
الكهربائيه اللي خلت شبكه قطرات الكيان
المحتل الوليد متطوره وفعاله وسريعه
وبعتوا للاسرائيليين عدد كبير من
الاتوبيسات الحديثه لدرجه ان نص عدد
الاتوبيسات الاسرائيليه سنه
1962 كانت من المانيا الغربيه وعلى
المستوى البحري وسعوا ميناء حيفا وده ادى
لرفع تصنيفه الدولي بين اكبر موانئ العالم
من المركز الرابع للمركز الثاني وبعتت
شركات بناء السفن الالمانيه للاسرائيليين
59 سفينه واربع سفن ركاب وعدد من المراكب
الخاص طيب هل اكتفت المانيا الغربيه ومن
وراها امريكا بكده لا طبعا وانما مدت الخط
على استقامته وساعدت المانيا الغربيه
الاسرائيليين يحسنوا انظمه الهاتف
والتلغراف وقتها وبعتوا لهم معدات
لاستغلال المعادن والثروات الطبيعيه اللي
هي بتاعه الفلسطينيين اصلا وبانوا لهم
مصنع للنحاس وده كان وقتها احد اهم مصادر
الدخل القومي للكيان المحتل ومصنع تاني
للصلب وركبت المعدات الالمانيه صنع عموما
في حوالي 1300 مصنع وبعتت المانيا الغربيه
حوالي 200000 طن حديد والاف الاطنان من
مواد خام ثانيه لتشغيل المصانع دي وعلى
مستوى الزراع مدوا 280 م م من خطوط انابيب
توصيل المال العملاقه لري منطقه النقب على
مستوى المساعدات العسكريه فكان معروف سنه
1964 ان المانيا الغربيه كانت بتدرب جنود
الاحتلال وبتزود اسرائيل بالاسلحه بشكل
سري ما تمش الاعلان عنه الا من تسع سنين
بس وتحديدا في 2014 لما عرفنا من خلال
وثائق اسرائيليه اترفع عنها السريه ان
حكومه المانيا الغربيه سلمت الاسرائيليين
اوائل الستينات 50 طياره و200 دبابه
امريكيه وغواصين وست زوارق سريعه وعدد من
الشاحنات وصواريخ مضاده للطائرات وصواريخ
مضاده للدبابات اكيد مش محتاج اقول لكم
لما نيجي ندي كل ده لكيان محتل ناشئ ايه
اللي هيحصل لقوته اكيد هتتعامل بشكل غير
طبيعي وهين عكس ده كله على قوه الكيان
المحتل العسكريه وبالفعل هنلاقي ان
التقنيات المتطوره والمدهش الالمانيه
وتقدمهم المبهر وقتها في انتاج الطاقه
الكهربائيه ومنظومات النقل والاتصالات
وانتاج الحديد والصلب وكل اللي زودوا به
الاسرائيليين عزز جدا في الخمسينات من
القدرات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في مواجهه
العرب وعزز من مقاومه الصهاينه لاي حلول
سلميه وساهم بشده في التوسع الاست اني في
فلسطين وفي المقابل المانيا قالت
للفلسطينيين مافكمش والدليل على ده ان
كونراد اديناور اول مستشار لالمانيا في
الخمسينات واوائل الستينات واللي بيسموه
صانع المانيا الحديثه لما اتسال على دعم
المانيا لاسرائيل في مقابل عدم التزام
المانيا بدعم اللاجئين الفلسطينيين قال
والله يا جماعه احنا ما لناش الحق كالمان
ولا عندنا القدره على اتخاذ اي موقف بشان
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الالمان برروا
تصرفاتهم دي بانه يا جماعه اعذرونا بس
احنا عندنا التزام اخلاقي مافيش فيه نقاش
تجاه ضحايا الاضهاد الناز اليهود لكن ده
مش صحيح بالمره والحقيقه التاريخيه ان
الجمهوريه الاتحاديه اللي هي المانيا
الغربيه كان عندها اهداف اقتصاديه وسياسيه
ضد المانيا الشرقيه اللي كانت خاضعه وقتها
للاتحاد السوفيتي وعلشان المانيا الغربيه
تحقق اهدافها دي كان لازم تاخد دعم
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي حاولت ترضيها
بشتى الطرق وعلشان كده لما امريكا طلبت
المانيا الغربيه تمول وتدعم دوله الاحتلال
الناشئه بالشكل الرهيب ده الحكومه
الالمانيه قالت سمعا وطاعه المانيا
الغربيه يا اخوانا كانت حريصه جدا جدا على
الاندماج في الغرب بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه لان ده كان ل مزايا مهمه جدا زي
توسع فرص الاعمال التجاريه الالمانيه
الغربيه في البلاد الراس ماليه ومناطق
نفوذها وزياده نفوذ القاده السياسيين
الالمان في دواير صناعه القرار الغربيه
الاهم من ده ان مستقبل الاقتصادي لالمانيا
الغربيه وقتها كان مرتبك وغير واضح
المعالم خالص بدون مساعده امريكا يعني
مستوى المعيشه فيها كان منخفض مقارنه
بمعظم دول اوروبا الغربيه وبال المانيا
النازيه نفسها قبل الحرب وفي نفس الوقت
امريكا كانت بتضغط بشده على الاوروبيين
الغربيين عموما علشان ينتجوا اسلحه بكثافه
وده خلاهم ما عندهمش القدره على انتاج اي
سلع للاستهلاك المحلي او التصدير وبالتالي
فضلت اسواقهم مفتوحه قدام المنتجات
الامريكيه مقابل ان الاسلحه اللي بينتجو
دي وبالاخص المانيا محتاجه تروح لاماكن
تستهلكها وفي مؤتمر لندن للديون في فبراير
1952 اصرت امريكا اللي هي اكبر دائن
لالمانيا الغربيه على ان المانيا تسدد
ديونها قبل الحرب وبعدها واللي هي ديون
خطه مارشال كل ده خلى من الصعب جدا على
الالمان الغربيين انهم يتجاهلوا مطالب
واشنطن فيما يتعلق باي شيء مهم وعلى را
راس الاشياء المهمه دي اسرائيل وطبعا كلنا
عارفين ان الولايات المتحده تبنت الوجود
الاسرائيلي من نشاه الكيان المحتل ولحد
اللحظه بشكل كامل الاهم من كده ان اسرائيل
هددت مسؤولي المانيا الغربيه صراحه في
اجتماعاتهم المغلقه وقالوا لهم انكم لو ما
ساعدتنا المساعدات دي كلها هنسخن
الاقتصادي ليهود العالم بالكامل وهنش حرب
اقتصاديه على المانيا وده نقدر نعتبره من
اول مواقف اللي ظهر فيها تاثير اللوبي
الاسرائيلي على حكومات الدول الغربيه خط
الدعم الالماني التاريخي ده ما وقفش خاصه
الدعم العسكري ورغم مرور الزمن وسقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي وتوحيد المانيا الا ان
التزام المانيا التاريخي بامن الكيان
الزفر ووجوده استمر وطبعا كان ناتج اساسي
لاتباع السياسه الخارجيه الالمانيه
للسياسه الامريكيه شبر بشبر يعني في نهايه
التسعينات سلمت برلين للقوات البحريه لجيش
الاحتلال اول ثلاث غواصات من طراز دولفين
الالماني الاشهر والاقوى ودي صفقه دفعت
معظم تكاليفها الحكومه الالمانيه اللي كان
بيسها المستشار هيلموت شميث ثم المستشار
جرهارد شرودر بعدها استمر الخط ده مفتوح
وفي 2012 اتفقت المانيا برئاسه ميركل مع
الاسرائيليين بقياده نتنياهو على بيع اربع
غواصات جديده نوويه متطوره يمكن تسلحها
برؤوس نوويه دفعت المانيا جزء معتبر من
ثمنهم رغم بعض بعض الخلافات اللي كانت ما
بين ميركل ونتنياهو حوالين استمرار بناء
الاحتلال للمستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه
والصفقه دي لما تمت دفعت السفير
الاسرائيلي السابق لالمانيا يوران بن زيف
انه يوصف ميركل بانها صديقه حقيقيه
لاسرائيل وان امن اسرائيل هو مبدا شخصي
ليها يتجاوز الخلافات واي اعتبار ثاني
اسطول الغواصات النوويه ده اللي باعت
المانيا معظمه للاسرائيليين في خلال الش
سنين اللي فاتوا ساهم جدا جدا في حمايه
منصات الغاز والنفط البحريه الاسرائيليه
ضد صواريخ حزب الله والصواريخ الايرانيه
تحديدا ويساهم في ان الاحتلال يبسط سيطرته
على مناطق اقتصاديه بحريه مهمه جدا في
البحر المتوسط وخاصه المناطق المتاخمه
لسواحل لبنان طبعا مهم هنا نقول ان الموقف
الالماني ده والسياسات الالمانيه التي لا
تتوقف عن صناعه وبيع الاسلحه للاسرائيليين
وتاييده عموما هي سياسات جربها
الفلسطينيين في صراعات بقى مش في الصراع
الحالي بس واللي هنتكلم عنه بعد شويه يعني
بيع الغواصات دي تم في عز مكان الاحتلال
بيقصف قطاع غزه في 2014 وبيرت كب جرائمه
هناك وفي الوقت ده وبعد ايام قليله من بدء
قصف الاحتلال للقطاع وقتله لمئات
الفلسطينيين وقفت انجلا ميركل اللي نادرا
لما بتحضر اي مظاهرات قدام الالاف في
مسيره احتجاجيه اتعملت ضد تصاعد معادات
سميه وقالت بالنص ان اي شخص بيهاجم اليهود
في المانيا فهو بيهاجم المانيا كلها وقالت
ان وجود اكثر من 100000 يهودي بيعيشه في
المانيا دلوقتي هو بمثابه معجزه وهديه
بتحسسها بالامتنان العميق وقالت ان الحياه
اليهوديه جزء من هويته ثقافه الالمان
الكلام ده اللي ممكن ما تكونو سمعتوه حتى
من مسؤولين اسرائيليين بيوضح تماما مدى
النفوذ الاسرائيلي في المانيا بالاخص من
خلال فزاعه معادات السلاميه وضح لكم مدى
تبعيه المانيا عموما لخط السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه علشان كده اول زعيم غربي وصل
الاراضي المحتله وقابل نتنياهو بعد عمليه
المقاومه مباشره كان المستشار الالماني
الحالي اف شولتس واللي ابد دعمه المطلق
لحق الكيان المحتل في الدفاع عن نفسه وقال
هو جنب نتنياهو في مثل هذه الاوقات الصعبه
لا يوجد سوى مكان واحد يمكننا ان نكون فيه
بجانب اسرائيل كلام شولتس كان واضح برده
من خلال الدعم العسكري غير المحدود اللي
اديته المانيا للاسرائيليين وده هيبان
لينا من خلال ارتفاع صادرات الاسلحه
الالمانيه للكيان المحتل في شهر اكتوبر
واللي انعكس على صادرات المانيا العسكريه
في السنه الحاليه 2023 لجيش الاحتلال
واللي تعدت ال 300 مليون يورو منها ذخاير
المانيه فتاكه بلغت قيمتها حوالي 20 مليون
يورو وده كله ولسه السنه ما خلصتش ورقم ال
300 مليون يورو ده هو 10 اضعاف قيمه اللي
صدرته المانيا من اسلحتها للكيان في 2022
طبعا التاييد الالماني ده للاحتلال ما
كانش في صوره صادرات اسلحه بس وانما زي ما
قلنا في اول الحلقه خد صور كتير سياسيه
وثقافيه وامنيه ومها مداهمه الشرطه واجهزه
المخابرات من ثلاث اسابيع بس ل 54 عقار في
اطار حمله على اللي وصفتهم السلطات
الالمانيه بالاسلاميين المناهضين لاسرائيل
وفتحت السلطات دي تحقيق مع المركز
الاسلامي في هامبورج وده واحد من اكبر
واقدم المنظمات الاسلاميه في المانيا
واتهمته باجراء تواصلا مع ايران وحزب الله
اللبناني فلو جمعنا ده كله هنطلع منه بان
موقف المانيا ده المؤيد للكيان المحتل
بشكل غير مشروط تقريبا زي ما بيرضي امريكا
وبيحافظ على توجهات النخب الالمانيه
ومصالحهم مع واشنطن ومع الاسرائيليين فهو
برده بيحط المانيا في مشاكل حقيقيه في
الداخل مع المسلمين اللي عايشين على
اراضيها ومشاكل خارجيه مع قوى مؤيده
للفلسطينيين زي اغلب الدول العربيه
وشعوبهم وروسيا وتركيا وبعض قوى العالم
الجنوبيه اللي المانيا حريصه جدا على
علاقات كويسه معاها زي اندونيسيا
والبرازيل وجنوب افريقيا وكل دول على
الجانب الفلسطيني من الصراع والمانيا مش
عاوزه توترات خالص معاهم لمختلف الاسباب
السياسيه والاقتصاديه في المعتاد في
المانيا معظم الوقت عندها توجه سياسي عام
من بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه بعدم وجود
مانع من قيام دوله فلسطينيه بل بالعكس
بتايد الحل ده لكن بتايد وجود دوله
فلسطينيه مدنيه على المقاس كده لا بتهش
ولا بتنش ولا تقارن على الاطلاق بدوله
الاحتلال وفي المقابل هيظل الالتزام
الالماني تجاه اسرائيل مكمل بل وبيزيد في
الخطاب الرسمي والنخبوية
سنين بتعزز من خلال دعايه جباره للمحرقه
واحياء ذكراها بشكل مستمر ونشرها بكل
الاشكال في الثقافه الالمانيه الشعبيه بدا
يواجه في العدوان الاخير ازمه بانت من
خلال عدم تاييد عموم الالمان لسياسات
الحكومه الالمانيه الداعمه للاسرائيليين
بالشكل الفج ده ده هنشوفه مثلا من خلال
استطلاع الراي اللي عمله معهد انس باخ
الالماني واللي اظهر ان غالبيه الالمان
بيعرضوا بشده تاييد المانيا اسرائيل
وتقديم الدعم العسكري ليها وهنشوف برده من
خلال الرساله اللي كتبها عدد من الشخصيات
الالمانيه والدوليه البارزه ردا على
الفيلسوف الشهير يورجن هابرماس اللي ايد
حق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها ورغم انهم
في الرساله وكما هو متوقع ادانه هجوم حماس
لكنهم ذكروا ان المدنيين الفلسطينيين في
غزه بيواجهوا الموت والدمار وانه احتمال
يرقى ما في غزه الى مستوى الاباده
الجماعيه طبعا ده قياسا على المتوقع منهم
واللي احنا شايفينه بال فعل تغيير كبير في
الصراع ودليل من ضمن ادله كتير جدا على ان
السرديه الفلسطينيه بتخوض المعركه بشكل
كويس جدا وبتحقق اختراقات مهمه جدا وبتنسي
الروايه الاسرائيليه في معاقل نفوذها
الغربيه واللي كانت ما بتشوفش غير روايه
الاحتلال بس ورغم كل التهديدات الرسميه
الالمانيه لكن المظاهرات المؤيده
للفلسطينيين في المانيا بتتحدى كل ده
ومستمره لحد اللحظه وعلشان كده زي ما قلت
لكم يبدو ان الروايه الاسرائيليه في
المانيا بتواجه ازمه اكبر من اي وقت فات
ويبدو ان شرايح الشباب الالماني خاصه
اليساريين منهم بداوا يفكروا في الروايه
الاسرائيليه وما ياخدوها بشكل مسلم بيه زي
ما الجيل القديم بيعمل مش عايز اطول على
حضراتكم اكتر من كده لحد هنا انا خلصت
كلامي وكالعاده عندي سؤال ليكم هل شايفين
ان اللي بيحرك المانيا لمساعده اسرائيل هي
عقده الذنب ولا الضغط الامريكي وليه هتابع
كل اجاباتكم في التعليقات هتلاقوا تحت
الفيديو بيانات شركه تفيت علشان لو انت
مستورد وحابب تتعامل معاهم وتستورد من
خلالهم المنتجات دي بفكركم بالتفاعل مع
الفيديو علشان يظهر في ظل القيود المعموله
في مختلف منصات التواصل الاجتماعي على
المحتوى المؤيد للقضيه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
سلام
ا